mais je crois que c'est tard je pense
qu'il ya quelques problèmes d'argent
mais je pense aussi que nous pouvons
gagner notre vie
j'aimerais donc demandé une sorte de
soutien je suis sûr que certaines
personnes seront sans emploi
même si je travaille toujours j'espère
donc qu'il y aura une forme d' aide pour
ceux qui perdent leur emploi
j'espère qu'il y aura moins de contacts
entre humains que le risque d'infection
sera réduit et que de nombreuses
personnes ne seront pas infecté je pense
que c'est la bonne méthode
[Musique]
oui la vie serait très ennuyeuse non si
vous ne pouvez aller nulle part
alors dès que possible afin de retrouver
notre vie ordinaire je vais essayer de
me contrôler et de rester à la maison si
le gouvernement avait traité chacun des
problèmes plus rapidement je ne pense
pas que le virus se serait répandue ok